I'm here [music]
[music]
I'm not going to pull it out here
.
I'll show
you, if you shut yourself up in your room for 31 days and play games,
you'll
get tired
.  Music]
Assuming it's a fantasy world, fate is a promised loyalty
crap.
[Music]
[Applause]
It was a little too early to use magic, is
n't it?  Yo,
it's the money of Dogo country, so you can use it if it's
gunny Well, that's the first question I
asked.  It's
not summoned to another world, but I posted my main character's setting.
Probably no accidents in the precincts.
I can't accept the leeway in laws and regulations unless we have a full welfare system
Epic Gulliver has one
ban If the
movie is a top and bottom in the first place, it's the beautiful girl
who summoned me.  The beautiful girl who boarded the ship
Jean What kind of brim is
it?  I'm sorry,
jeez
[music] It's been
4 days,
so don't you think you've changed your mind now?
Demonstrating my power is a big promise
I'm going to knock down my bright future character
That's why I'm a strong
adrenaline user
.
Sugumo no Kai Jie
[Music]
Stolen, let's protect it Please,
that's something important I can give up on other things, but that's the only thing I ca
n't do Because I'm
a good girl  If you ask me if I'm related to you, all I can
do is say no.
But that's not a situation that can be overlooked pr
I bought a joking house
Well, it's probably twice, but I don't know what it is, but it's a painful child I thought I won, but oh
yeah Taichi is unfair  Maybe then
, if it's two bodies, I guess it's an equal condition
If you want to withdraw right now with five spirit magicians, I'll make a decision right away and hurry up.
If you do, I'll curse you until the end of time.In this case, it's Matsushiro, but I said I
'm saved.It's a tour, so I didn't move.
It's just a boyish reaction and I didn't feel any wickedness, but Puck is silent
You know a rare strategy from me, don't you?
No way, if I really went there, I'd taken a detour, so I
better chase after it as soon as
possible.
I can't help you I won't help you
Who is that gal car? It's a smart plan to at
least let you live happily until you wake up.
There are times
when I've turned into a change I'm glad I'm a child If it wasn't so bad, it seems like you ended up hanging out with me until you woke up Don't get me wrong I have something
I want to ask, so I had no choice but to stay, so heal the wounds on your body
It was for my sake that I gave
it to you, and that you let me use
your bag as a pillow until I woke up.  You have an idea about the weather, don't you
?  That can't be helped, right? But you don't know anything, so you gave me information That's why I told you about how
I healed my injuries.
You should be
fine as usual, but from now on, it's dangerous to go into a popular
topic by yourself, so don't worry about it, China
.
I'm sorry, it's not sumo wrestling.
Don't let me, a total stranger, feel indebted To me, it's a shitty
way of life I'm just going to
lose money Jaeger
Noi I'm waiting for you I'll tell you what I'm
saying but I can only go out with
you for a little while I see a little  But, ah, it's more important than
that. Please help me too,
but you don't know anything.
No, I want to thank you for the money, so I want to help you.
That's right, it's
one good thing for a day.
[music  ]
Me
, the street entrance is big, but this town isn't too big to look for things.
Hey, let
me introduce myself.
It's really rare to come into contact with the Holy Spirit so
casually Where did you come from
?  I don't
know where I am right now, I don't have money,
I can't read, and I don't have anyone to rely on.
Yes,
my name is My name  But
Subaru is a pretty family, is
n't it?  But if I haven't heard your name, then my name is transporting
I'm
Satella, I'm not a member
.
I don't feel like it's time for the child, no,
so it's important to listen to them, but
if you're a lost child, you have to do something about
it.
Tuvalu,
if you say you can't keep up with me, that's fine. Thank you so far
Subaru.
I'll do something about it myself.
Didn't you have a father or mother with you?
I
'm going to crush it It's amazing when it hits me
[Music]
Now that it's gone, I put it in a place like this.
I'll let my brother and sister open it and I'll find it in a few minutes.
I think Subaru and this girl can only be seen as siblings, but
why am I so younger?
It's
easy, so we can comfortably continue our search
, right? More importantly, why did you help Subaru?
If you go, can you help me find the weather
?  Well, tomorrow's schedule is brought
forward I'm planning to finish this week's quota first
Subaru has a very stubborn personality
That's why I don't think you and I are treated as younger.
[MUSIC
] What's the matter? Hey, I'm a
half-elf, right?
[MUSIC]
Me
?  I'm not
sure if it's the 3rd term, so it's fine, but even if I get angry and compare it to a mystery, I'm going to choose which song it's going to take.
No, I have to start the continuation of the search
Come on, well, even if I move around completely without a bra, I can't get good results
here.
Somehow the scene is around here
I came back after bravely declaring that I should leave it to
you.
No, Dora, I brought you a candidate, Mr. V,
to give you an example.
What did you want to say in the situation that just happened?
Actually, I was looking for someone, but I was wondering if you could talk to me for a moment
.
It's the
owner's shop in this place, so I stopped in for a bit
.  It
seems like she wants to thank her in her own way, so
[music]
Thank you
Yeah, yeah, that
's
amazing.  It's been good for us to go around with my nee-chan
[music
] The atmosphere and the art table There is also a personality of a person who lives here.
You're famous, aren't you? I don't
know where you live.
Whether it's going forward or going back, make a decision quickly I'm almost out of time but it's
already limited
I'm going back to the crystal stone and preparing while Tendou-sama is out
Well, on average, 9:00 to 5:00 is ideal
.
But it's okay, I have no choice but to move on here.
You summon me with the ocher
Then I asked you Subaru Ah
[Applause]
Hey  Alone with an ugly girl has been a situation since I was in elementary
school.You can't think weird things.You can use magic.Don't think about
it
.  It's an existence before it becomes a spirit.As time goes by, when you grow up and gain strength and self-consciousness, you
'll
become a fine spirit like Puck.
I wonder if the
fire spirit said that he saw a person who looked like Felt in this direction
, but 8 gigantic cell is this house after this.
I
wonder if the sleeves were stolen by my brothers and Phil.
Anyway, leave this to me
I'll try to negotiate somehow
Okay, I'll try to leave it to Bal Ok I'll leave it to you obediently.
I
'm going to burst out laughing, I'm hurt by that remark, but it's a development that
renews my determination.
I wonder if it's going to be a lie, but I'll
try to believe in Subaru
Yeah,
if it goes well, I'll be more motivated to drive with the feeling that it's about profit, and
I'll do
my best for me
Go for it, I'll be the first to go in. You won't be late on your way home, but it's okay to eat first.
You
can't use the button, yeah, it's nothing I'll
apologize properly if I can recover the rarity, so I
'll be the champion So,
if it's a fantasy, it's either a demon or a snake?
There must be a certain amount of carelessness in dealing
with it.
no  So this all supports me over
fb 8 e 0 He's seriously dangerous
]
I did a solo like Onii-chan,
Oh, that
's why Lingada Yuin-nii-chan has money, huh
?
There's no immortal sentence
Then hey, ah, what's the matter with dried cod with other medicines?
Oh
, I guess I was told by Puck that I was a morning teller on the breakout Satella. Anyway, I'm not
going back to that store
.  If you're alone with the dentist or
what you said earlier,
don't be shy
Please help me while I'm away from the
Ikeda family.
It was a
70-plane rover Don't be in a
hurry here Don't get in the way with the latitude Don't be freaked out Hey,
well, I've come this far and I'm not going home without looking at the answer
Can anyone tell me who's there?
Tekuteku weakening 6 c 4 a
Aizu by Koto is rather smashing the door, hey ant Eh, what is it that I
've
been fidgeting since a while ago
?  Fourth, don't get into the story from the cattle net
.
g 3 I haven't died recently.
It
's all a dream, so
from where to where is it that I'm in a world
like this?  I'm looking for
a beautiful silver-haired girl who helped me.
But I didn't bring that kind of item.
Promise me, if you tell me in advance that it's good quality, I'm sure there
's a good chance you're looking for
something.
But whether you can finish it or not buy it is another story.
Otani takes a strange thing because it's heavy to pick up and drop off
Tetenaruan For example, this is a component + it's a plum.
It's easy to understand that there are people with money and people without money in the world of
Dogo.
What are you doing, I'm getting in the way
Felt Oh, do you know me?
I don't have free time, so remember that it's a shocking way to meet someone, even if there
's some kind of
dat.  If that's the case, then listen to the story Tax
Otsu unread hugging butt Mario leroy Precious Dora Who's sorry?
I guess you didn't put it in and dilute it.
I've been told a lot of
things up until now
, but should I
let this old man play a good game?
The right hand that came came Collusion and came to anger me, didn't
I?
Shilomon is my legal domicile, and I went through a lot of hard work to obtain it.
If it's worth the money, I'm happy with the sound
.
Music]
I took it out here is a town that freezes the time of all things It's an
eternal era.
Ellen is
a mysterious item
that cuts out time and freezes it.
That's the popularity of the mansion, Meteor, who asks people about the game replenishment meter.
It's my first time to
use another right hand after death
.  It's not just my brother, but the
reason why I got rid of my
temper is because I was asked to do it.  I don't quite understand the market value of 10 gold coins,
but if it's the right Tiga you brought, at least you'll have double back
money
.  I
'm worried about where and when I'll meet the client, but here's the negotiating place.
You're my guest.  If you come,
eh,
I don't know if it's okay or not, but I'm not
ignorant.
In
terms of places, everyone is desperate for their own
survival, but in order for young children to survive, it's normal for them to team up with children who have similar circumstances, but
Felt feels that way too, so the city feels like Felt.
After all, it was the opposite of me
. I feel like there are a lot of outsiders sitting here, but
I wonder if I'll change if I'm overwhelmed by the sea
.  Brother, this brother is your
rival,
my other negotiating partner.
I don't hate you because you have a nice personality So
how much did your brother
pay?
It's been approved that 20 days of fresh bacteria is silly.Hey,
actually, I've been given a certain amount of extra money from the client, so I'm
thinking of adding a little extra.
It's the reason why you want it.
I don't know if that's all the gold coins I've been given by my employer.
Mr. Meteor is 20 pieces under the administration Delon and Mizou
Yo
is Mr.'s likener This negotiation leans toward this kid It
's bad for you and your employer, but it's not about returning it to that gold coin bag and changing it
car It
's a princess, isn't it?  I was so happy that I didn't
say anything else, so I'm going to have a good time
.  It's bad that the employer is thinking of paying less,
so the negotiations were disappointing, but I'm sorry about this.
Come to think of it, what are you going to do with that rare
acquisition
?
From the beginning of the meeting, it's hard to come to Secom light rain, and I'm Eisa with radish claws.
You're the one with more courage
, but if you face it, you might get hurt, but even if you
don't fight back, you'll get a cop skiing, or if someone
like that makes a move, your hands might go crazy.
I'm bad because I handled my cutlery
badly I got caught up in a
sweaty stance
[music]
Your meta is c
th
kabun Even
though the
old man and the girl are collapsing, you don't move Did you
give up?
No
[music]
me
me As you
can see, I'm an amateur, and I don't have the skills to move, but at least I think
I can narrow it down.
If it had been done earlier, the kids
might have been a little different, but
okay okay okay
[music]
Let's finish it I'll follow the disciples
.  I got my stomach when we passed each other I can
only explain this 7
After all
, I thought your intestines had a very beautiful color It's hard
to understand when I'm full It's hard to understand
.
I was
waiting rar na na na na aname ni Hahahahaha
What's the matter, brother, you suddenly took it off,
are you okay, brother?
Music]
Hmmm
Star seller who waits for stability
I wonder if he
disappeared after 8 games in Aki  music]
anti  I
don't know who you are, but
what do you mean by calling people by their living names
rar
[music]
me
aname
[music]
rel
ah ah ah
me
goo
n that yununuaaaaaa
[music]
nan
oh oh oh
[music]
temperature me
ni
[music]
[applause]
me
[music]
[music]  ]